[Music]
it's time for you to get your mRNA
vaccine so we can fix climate change
[Applause]
puny
go people it is January 23rd 2024 I'm
Dave Ruben this is the Ruben report we
are live streaming on Rumble YouTube and
locals oh and for the first time ever
today we're giving you people on the
Instagram if you've got that on your
computer phone uh five minutes of the
show just testing it out seeing what
happens if we put the first five minutes
of the show on Instagram and then if you
want to jump over and of course watch us
on rumble or or elsewhere so we're going
to just test that thing out today
postgame show as always Ruben report.
locals.com and before I do anything else
and we got a jam-packed show for you
today uh before I do anything else I
want to mention uh that yesterday we
broke the record of most Channel views
across platforms that we have ever had
in the history of this show and what is
interesting about that that's of course
always nice when we break any uh record
is that yesterday Monday breaking that
record it was a record that we had set
on Sunday and that was also a record
that we had set on Saturday and it was
also a record we had set on Friday so
for the last four days every single day
we have broke the most views across all
platforms which obviously is awesome and
it shows that there is at least a little
bit of a sanity movement in this country
I think it also shows a theory that I've
put out there for quite some time which
is that if you just do what you think is
right and if you build it they will come
you know a lot of people said to me Dave
if you if you go with to santis the
Trump people are going to be pissed
you're going to lose your audience I
always talk to you guys about audience
capture that one of the problems that I
think so many people in this business
have is you start seeing you get clicks
by doing a certain thing and and then
you just go more to that and then then
it ends up becoming a grift right it
doesn't become something honest and real
it just becomes the constant quest for
clicks and for and for cash basically uh
I've done what I thought is right this
entire time but particularly I think in
this last year and I think ultimately uh
the numbers have uh borne that out so
that's uh that's pretty sweet and I'm
feeling good about that uh and that gets
us to what the theme of the show is
today which is that you know with all of
this diversity equity and inclusion talk
and all of the Marxist nonsense that has
been pushed on us for these last couple
years in America but especially in this
last year uh I think over the last few
months there finally is a real serious
concerted push back against it and not
only is there a push back against it but
as we talked about yesterday now a whole
bunch of people are just saying no no no
no no no no whether they're MMA fighters
or whether they're Donald Trump or
whether they're school board members or
whoever else enough people now are
finally saying you're all Bs artists we
don't want anything to do with you and
of course we will see how that that kind
of lays out what happens in this
political year going forward and of
course I should mention also that today
is the New Hampshire primary so we will
see is this Nikki Haley's Last Stand or
will uh will she do all right because it
is an Open Primary you might get some
Democrats some crossover people uh and
maybe she'll does okay and then that
pushes her towards South Carolina which
is her State and then maybe towards
super Tuesday but we're not even going
to cover that today today we're diving
deep on the Dei stuff and the push back
because I want people to understand that
there are a whole bunch of confused
people on this right like you've got
your Mark Cuban types that are pushing
Dei who I think are kind of
well-intentioned but confused about the
issues then you've got your sort of Joy
Reed types uh and the and the academic
layer types who are the true marxists
and Communists and everything else but
enough people are now pushing back and I
want to start uh well you know what
let's start actually by a little clip
that I did I was part of this little
thing you guys know I was on Gutfeld
with an exclamation point over over
there on Fox News uh on Friday night and
uh Greg was talking about the
unpopularity the sudden growing
unpopularity of the Dei movement in
America I think that'll set us up nicely
it's literally impossible to create
equal outcomes in a universe of
individuals that's why you rarely see a
virtual tie in a foot race Dei is the
most anti- individualist Endeavor ever
for it assumes that there's no diversity
among individual talents
which is why they hamper Excellence by
promoting mediocrity and now we're
preaching this crap in the greatest
military on the planet why don't we just
turn the keys to the Pacific Fleet over
to the Chinese right now this is
supposed to be the only place left that
depends on meritocracy but then again if
you look around the rest of the
America's storied institutions we've
ditched that gold standard so why should
the military be any different look I
just want the deadliest military on
Earth not the most diverse I don't care
if our soldiers are straight I just want
them to shoot
straight Dave it's it's so weird because
what we're seeing right now is everybody
running from Dei even Democratic
candidates are running from it and yet
this is still up on the Navy website
does this scare you Greg I will talk
about that but can we talk about your
glasses first because you you look like
a middle-aged lesbian
poet which which actually might be Dei
for Fox because I Dei is as you laid out
it it is the reverse of everything that
America was founded upon which of course
is equality of opportunity and nobody
the thing is nobody in America cares
about this stuff except the people that
are bludgeoning us with it and until we
just get back to not caring about
whether your doctor is black or white or
your pilot is Black or White if we're
going to care about that we're going to
have an awful lot of planes falling out
of the sky and we're going to have a lot
of doctors that know how to perform
surgery and that would be problematic
but also it be a lot of
fun okay putting aside Gregs lesbian uh
glasses uh the point is that if we are
going to inject something other than
skill in our military and with our
pilots and with our doctors then we are
going to degrade ra the entire system
right we will have a military that it
was a good line that will not be able to
shoot straight we will have doctors that
won't be able to perform surgery we will
have Pilots that do not know how to fly
planes I should know real quick we're
going to jump over if you're watching on
Instagram we're about to cut the feed so
join us on Rumble uh right about now
that was a little test we'll see what
happens uh but the point of all of this
is what has happened I I know you guys
know all of this you guys know Dei is
not good you guys know that racism isn't
good we should have put all of this
stuff to bed we thought it was put to to
bed and then these people woke it up so
what happened what happened over the
last couple months that suddenly it
seems like it is not cool anymore to be
into Dei that now we're exposing the
Karens and the hysterical people and the
marxists and everything else well I
think something very obvious happened uh
and I think you actually know the date
that it happened on there is a specific
date that this thing all started turning
around and that is the 7th of October
and we all know what happened that day
and now I'm going to connect that to
everything else uh but real quick let me
talk to you guys about TWC Health guys
recent clusters of respiratory illnesses
in northern China alongside outbreaks of
what's being referred to as the white
lungs syndrome in the United States are
scattered across the headlines right now
drawing attention to the importance of
being prepared for medical emergencies
with close to 90% of pharmaceuticals in
the US being produced outside of the US
what happens when the next Global crisis
strikes countries clamp down on exports
they stockpile the price of drugs rise
and the pharmacy shelves in America
become empty this is already starting to
happen so what's your solution you guys
have heard me talk about the wellness
company before but when we're staring
down the barrel of Times Like These
their medical emergency kit is a
musthave the wellness company is home to
Dr Peter Mulla Dr Drew Pinsky who's
going to be live in studio next Monday
and truth-telling doctors who are rooted
in their commitment to building a
parallel Health Care system and
empowering you to take control of your
health in a time when over 40% of
Americans say they would avoid a doctor
or Hospital unless it was a catastrophic
situation the wellness company's medical
e Mercy kit provides a solution this
handy little kit includes eight
potentially life-saving medications for
you to keep on hand along with a guide
book for safe use the medical emergency
kit includes antibiotics antivirals
antiparasitics like amoxicillin zpac and
iberin to help keep you and your family
safe in times of natural disasters
supply chain shortages or medical
emergencies like white lung or covid go
to TWC health.com rubben and grab your
emergency health kit right now that's
tww c. Ruben code ruin saves you a 15%
of checkout and now back to me okay so
look 107 happens 2,000 Israelis killed
rapes murders bodies burned alive
children there are still 150 or so
hostages the sheer barbarity of it the
fact uh that the Hamas soldiers whatever
soldiers terrorists barbarians whatever
you want to call them that they
videotaped all of this they were live
streaming it on some of the victim's
phones uh they put out all to the world
to see right that's exactly what they
did with intent uh as many people have
pointed out over the last couple months
at least the Nazis and that attack on
107 was the worst most most amount of
Jewish people killed in a day uh since
the Holocaust uh but at least the Nazis
had the temerity to hide some of what
they were doing you know when you see
video of what they were doing now at
aitz or in some of the other
concentration camps they were recording
it for themselves and it was to be kept
private it was only exposed after the
Allies won the war they weren't
broadcasting it out to the world right
they were hiding their atrocities to the
world but Hamas wanted the atrocities to
be seen because of that and despite all
of the nonsense that we've seen you know
in the last few months since in terms of
backwards people protesting for Hamas
the very types of people that Hamas
would gladly kill if they were living in
their territory um a lot of people have
woke up people were shocked to see the
barbarity so I want to connect that to
something that happened yesterday Elon
Musk and Ben Shapiro visited the awit
museum it's not the they visited the
site of awit and then there is a museum
there uh and they talked a bit about
what has led to this now I would say
push back against some of the craziness
that uh we've been illustrating lately
now the crossover between you know some
of
these rallies on college campuses in
favor of Hamas I mean they unite the the
weirdest coalitions maybe in human
history you'll see lgbtq Flags in favor
of Hamas where of course if an lgbtq
person were to be actually in the Gaza
Strip they would no longer be in the
Gaza Strip they would be dead yes um
exact that that Coalition is that's like
seriously out of touch
[Laughter]
yeah but it isn't but it only isn't out
of touch in the sense that there is a
coalitional idea here that basically
power structures must be torn down at
cost and if that means allying with
people who hate me then I'll Ally with
people who hate me and and the fact that
that's grown in fervor since October 7th
really is you know as I said to me on on
a personal level quite shocking you know
what do you make of the future of a West
if if the West continues to embrace that
idea well I I think we really need to to
stop this principle that the the weaker
nor normally weaker party is always
right this is simply not true um if you
are in quotes oppressed or or the weaker
party it doesn't mean you're right um
because if some of those you know we
weaker uh groups want to annihilate you
that does not make them good we just we
have to get rid of the rule that that if
you're weaker you're automatically good
that's that's obviously makes no sense
um you know you know it often makes
sense whereas like okay you don't want
to beat up on someone smaller and weaker
than you
um but if that if that smaller group
wants to kill you that they're they're
bad okay you know it's interesting
because Elon for as absolutely brilliant
as he is it's like one of I think his
main skills is saying sort of complex
things in very simple ways like he uses
very simple language there just because
you are the perceived weaker group in
this case the the Palestinians it does
not mean you are good no matter what
you're perceiving depression is again
perceived depression you are not allowed
to burn babies alive and put them into
ovens you are not allowed to rape women
and murder men women and children in in
just the most Unthinkable possible ways
that does not make you good or just but
unfortunately that is what much of the
modern left now believes and then as Ben
points out they created this crazy
Coalition of people LGBT people for
Palestine gays for Palestine of course
is very different than Palestine for
gays like the you think think about it
if you're a Hamas fighter somewhere in
Gaza right now and you're seeing on
Twitter because they still do have
electricity you're seeing on Twitter
some gender queer weirdo in Berkeley
cheering you on like think how
absolutely hilarious you must think that
is but they thought the left thought
they could take all of these people they
could remove all of our individuality
which is the most important thing about
us that you have thoughts you have an
ability to ration and think about the
world world and reason and then put that
into action they thought they could
remove all that and then just say oh
you're Palestinian so you're oppressed
you're queer so you're oppressed you're
black so you're oppressed and then what
are we going to do we're going to
combine all of you like we're combining
a whole bunch of Transformers into a
much more big a much bigger powerful
robot and that will be the thing that
that basically destroys the west but
because of the sheer barbarity of
October 7th they are starting to realize
that that a lot of people are seeing
through the nonsense one way that you
can really see through the nonsense is
to not look at everything through their
oppressed oppressor prism and Elon
continued uh talking about that um I
mean I'm a big believer in moral
absolutism not moral relativism there is
there's good and bad in the
absolute um and you judge any group or
individual against absolute moral
standards not whether they they're the
so-called oppressed or oppressor just on
absolute moral terms are they doing good
things do they want to murder innocent
people that's bad it doesn't matter who
they are right so imagine if morals were
absolute not relative right not okay
occasionally you can rape women
occasionally you can burn babies alive
but if they were absolute we would not
be in this place we wouldn't have a
generation of people that would be so
confused fuse that would be out on the
streets Marching for causes that would
gladly see them enslaved or beheaded or
a whole bunch of other not good things
so the point is that Americans and
actually people all over the world the
good decent people were shocked to see
so many people who have been marching in
favor of genocide and what's going on on
the college campuses Harvard and the
other Elite schools and that is exactly
why Dei is becoming unpopular and it
also you could connect it to the rocket
fuel that is pushing Trump right now he
is viewed as the antidote to all of that
nonsense here's another one uh from Elon
and Shapiro talking about the root cause
in all of this and yeah you guys get it
already you know that theory of power
and group identity is really ugly and we
see Echoes of it today I mean the the
diversity equity and inclusion ideology
that basically suggests that all of
society is a vast pyramid of group
identity and that at the very top are
the people who are successful and that
those people are explo everybody else
and we can tell who's Successful by
their group identity not by their level
of success by their group identity that
matches up incredibly it syncs up almost
a v diagram ccle with anti-Semitism
absolutely the diversity actually
inclusion Ian you should always be
always be wary of any name that sounds
like it could come out of a George
Orwell book okay that's never a good
sign um and uh because it sounds like
sure diversity Equity inclusion these
all sound like nice words but but there
what what it really means is
discrimination on the basis of race uh
sex and um sexual orientation and uh and
and it's against Merit um and and thus I
think is fundamentally
anti-semitic so um yeah
um you know
the I I think the the whole all of the
sort of the the all all of the riots
that were in the uh major city and
college campuses I think was uh a
shocking wakeup call
to um I think
any any any sort of
civilization or civil minded person
really so there he gets to the thesis of
the show what caused the wakeup like why
is it so many people are suddenly like
oh this thing isn't good I've kind of
been involved in this diversity Equity
inclusion thing it kind of sounds good
what do I always say about all the ideas
of the left like it's a very thin vene
veneer right the veneer is pretty good
oh diversity Equity inclusion it kind of
sounds good those words all sound
positive and then you peel that thin
veneer and then you see something really
nasty underneath it now you can also see
as Ben and Elon are talking about that
why the world economic Forum types and
why all of big Tech and big government
why they hate Elon Musk because
everything he's talking about represents
the individual it represents you he
bought Twitter a failing product the
product that he is losing millions and
millions of dollars on every single
month he bought it so that more people
could have their voices out there right
so that they could fight all of these
bad ideas just imagine since October 7th
if he did not have Twitter we would have
virtually no idea what's going on in the
world I think you could also argue that
that Trump wouldn't have the momentum he
would have and more but elon's been
talking about this diversity Equity
inclusion thing uh since 107 and and
really even before that and we should
pay attention to because he is an
African-American don't forget that right
he is from South Africa
anyway here's a tweet from Elon about
diversity Equity inclusion where he just
kind of nailed it very simply I think
we've shown this one to you before Dei
must
di the point was to end discrimination
not replace it with different
discrimination and that is where we are
at right now the mainstream narrative
actually is constantly pushing
discrimination you should not be
discriminating against white people when
you're hiring that is discrimination you
should not be discriminating against
Asian students who want to get into
college that is discriminating you
should not generally be calling for the
Gen side of Jewish students at colleges
that would be a problem uh we're going
to get on the other side of this to uh
to some of the people that have been
confused about this because I think
there is people always say well where is
this all coming from what do these
people have in common and I think
there's kind of two buckets you have
your sort of well-intentioned but really
confused people sort of like the Mark
Cuban types we've talked about him a bit
over the last couple weeks and then you
have your the genuine bad actor types
who are pushing all of this so we'll get
to that after I talk to you guys about
moink box I think you know a little
something about boy box like that 60% of
us pork production comes from one
company owned by the Chinese and their
Hogs are given saying called ractopamine
which is banned in 160 countries
including China yet you find it in your
grocery aisle every day well guys
there's a better way that is moink which
of course is Moo plus oink moink
delivers grass-fed and grass finish beef
and lamp pasture pork and chicken and
sustainable wild CAU Alaskan salmon
straight to your door moink Farmers Farm
like our grandparents did and as a
result moink meat tastes like it should
because the Family Farm Does It Better
the moink difference is a difference you
can taste and you can feel good knowing
you're helping family farm stay
financially independent as well you
choose the meat delivered in every box
like like ribey to chicken breasts to
pork chops to Salmon filets and much
more plus you can cancel anytime Shark
Tank host Kevin o called moinks bacon
the best bacon he's ever tasted and they
guarantee you'll say oink oink I'm just
so happy I got moed keep American
farming going by signing up at moink
box.com Ruben right now and listeners of
this show get two free steaks in the
first box it's the best steak you'll
ever taste but for a limited time M
inkbox.com rubben moink box.com Rubin
and now back to me okay so I want to
unpack a little bit I think we've given
you sort of the the bumper sticker
version of what's wrong here that's
everything that Elon and Ben Shapiro
just laid out I think those are mostly
ideas you know but I think it's worth
noting that that those ideas are now
bubbling into the mainstream and that is
really really good right if you if you
watch this show if you get your news
from online people you're always going
to be a little bit ahead of the curve it
doesn't mean you're always going to be
right or I'm always going to be right
but you're going to be a little ahead of
the curve of what bumps into the
mainstream right and that is what we
just laid that's what Elon and Ben are
talking about it's what we're always
talking about here you know sort of
poking holes in this nonsense now the
issue is that there are well-intentioned
people who are not not racists or or
anything else who have bought a lot of
this nonsense uh and and pushed it out
in their own way one of these people is
Mark hban Mark hubin of course from
Shark Tank and he's a tech billionaire
and he has been one of the main people
on Twitter pushing these ideas of
diversity Equity inclusion so I want to
show you this tweet from Mark cubin this
is this is a new one because you may
remember about two weeks ago we did a
whole he got into a whole thing with
Elon Musk over diversity Equity
inclusion but he's still doing it it's
wild so here he goes uh this is this is
uh from about two weeks ago he says let
me help you out he's talking to Elon and
give you my thoughts on Dei diversity
good businesses look where others don't
to find the employees that will put your
business in the best possible position
to succeed you may not agree but I take
it as a given that there are people of
various races ethnicities orientation
Etc that are regularly excluded from
hiring consideration by extending our
hiring search to include them we can
find people that are more qualified the
loss of Dei phobic companies is my game
my gain 1A we live in a country with
very diverse demographics in this era
where Trust of businesses can be hard to
come by people tend to connect more
easily to people who are like them
having a Workforce that is diverse and
representative of your stakeholders is
good for business uh that was in a
response to a tweet can you put that up
for just one more second that was in
response to a tweet from Elon Musk where
he said that discrimination on the base
of race which Dei does is literally a
definition of racism now I want to say
something about Mark cubin here before
we get to his more recent tweet because
that one was about two weeks ago one of
the things he's saying there is that in
in essence you should that okay there's
different people and different people
think different things now that is true
it is also true that different black
people think different things not all
black people think the same thing not
all gay people think the same thing
white people etc etc but once you inject
that into your corporate hiring
practices you have degraded the pool
that is 100% true every single time we
have hired for the Ruben report when we'
put up a public hiring I don't mention
anything about diversity Equity
inclusion when we have our rounds of
hiring where my team goes through the
applicants first they go through the
resumés then they have zoom meetings
with them and then a couple people get
to me where I have a zoom meeting with
them it has literally nothing to do with
race we happen to have three white guys
in this room we've got an Asian guy in
the back room over there why we why do
we keep the Asian guy in the other room
that actually I've never thought of that
before Joey how you doing over there he
doing all right okay Joey's all right I
that's complete coincidence okay but the
point is I didn't hire him because he's
Asian and I didn't hire them because
they're white that in and of itself is
racist but but again I think what Mark
cubin is trying to do here I don't think
he is a racist I don't think he is a
like a communist lunatic I think he's
confused about the idea so now I want to
get you to a more recent we should let
Joey here I guess maybe we should um but
now I want to get to a more recent tweet
from Mark hubman check this out he wrote
with that in mind he's talking about di
diversity equ inclusion with that in
mind 94% of new jobs in the SNP 100
going to people of color sounds about
what we ought to expect it's not
evidence of employers going to
especially Great Lengths to hire
minorities or discriminating against
white workers are doing anything other
than fishing where the fish are If the
percentage were much lower than 90% that
would be caused for concern Connor leave
that up for just a moment because what
he's referencing there is a report came
out that the SNP 100 company
it's crazy you can't even believe this
you're looking at it right now but it is
true that 94% of the new jobs that they
hired last year were people of color and
what he's saying is that if that
percentage were much lower than 90% that
would be a cause for concern that is
racism it makes no sense whatsoever that
is clearly these companies which have
these diversity equity and inclusion
departments right they are looking at
candidates only based on the color of
their skin it is not to to say that all
of the people they hire are are
unqualified I'm sure some of them are
but I'm sure many of them aren't and why
unless you were a sort of Neo rist a
modern racist why would you be upset
that your company had 50% white people
what he's saying is oh if it was
anything less than 90% black and brown
that would be a problem why why would
you want to discriminate against Asian
people Joey should be able to decide
what we're having for lunch today I've
decided um you get it you get it I know
you get it uh but Mark Cuban he has a
long history of this and I think there's
there's something going on with him it's
partly because he's an owner of a
basketball team which has mostly black
players we'll get to that in a sec he
feels a little guilty he's white he's a
billionaire he feels a little guilty uh
you may remember this uh during the 2020
George Floyd Floyd riots when they were
burning down Pep Boys and Targets in the
name of diversity Equity inclusion and
all that good stuff uh talking about how
rioting and no justice no peace that's
really an allegiance to the American
flag you know all this stuff about the
flag and kneeling you know got me
thinking about the Pledge of Allegiance
you know I pledge allegiance to the flag
of the United States of America and to
the Republic for which it stands one
nation under God indivisible with
liberty and justice for all and we all
said that pledge growing up here in the
United States and going back to it
liberty and justice for all that's what
this flag is supposed to mean for all of
us and so when people kneel when people
stand up and protest it's specifically
what we pledge to do our entire lives in
school The Pledge to the United States
of America and our flag for liberty and
justice for all and when people chant no
justice no peace to me that's what they
mean that's what I hear and when people
kneel they're not turning away from the
flag they're turning towards the flag
and pushing for justice for all have you
as you may have noted in the upper
corner of that thing that was a video
that was put out by the official NBA
account during the riots uh the NBA of
course also put black lives matter logos
on the court we now know that the black
lives matter movement was a complete
giant grift it never set set a black
sent a black kid to college it never
helped a black businessman open a small
business or anything like that and again
here's where Mark cubin is just confused
of course you allowed to knels for the
flag if you so choose um just liberty
and justice all we have no laws that's
that discriminate against anyone in this
country on the basis of their skin uh
what most people were upset by when it
came to that Summer of Love in 2020 is
that they were burning down stores and
where I lived in Los Angeles off Ventura
Avenue which is a major drag there in
Los Angeles that all of the stores were
boarded up and they all put BLM signs
and they would say how many employees of
color they had there because they didn't
want their stores to be burned down in
in the name of Tolerance and diversity
and love so there is a difference
between peaceful protest and burning
down stores or say what they're doing
now as they've morphed it into a Hamas
protest uh blocking Bridges going to
people's homes etc etc but he's been
confused about this for a while and Mark
cubin if if you're watching this and
we've interacted a little bit on Twitter
I'm doing this in a weird way I'm I'm
not trying to attack you too personally
I'm trying to not impune your motives
because I think you could come around on
the right side of this but I want to
show you that that the confusion that so
many people have had have led to so many
of the problems that we are having in
Western Society right now here's a
little bit more of Mark Cuban back in
2020 I need all of us to really open up
and talk to each other even when it's
difficult even when it's not something
that we're comfortable with particular
those of you who look like me the white
Community because is hard to discuss
race when you're white the reality is
just to be brutally honest when people
talk about white privilege we get
defens mechanism I call manufacturing
equivalent to try to protect ourselves
we'll say well I have a lot of black
friends we'll say that I grew up in a
mixed community so I'm not like that I
can't possibly be someone who Tak of
white PR we manufactur
this and it's incumbent upon us to stop
doing that so look Mark feels guilty
right he is a white billionaire he feels
guilty about the success that he has had
in his life and he's trying to pay
Penance to these people right he's
trying to bow to them white privilege is
a completely nonsensical madeup term uh
there there are no white power
structures America has no racist law
laws everyone has every opportunity to
do whatever they want it doesn't mean we
all started in the same place and it
certainly doesn't mean we're all going
to end up in the same place and if there
were laws that were stopping a certain
set of people based on the color of
their skin from doing anything that
would be a problem but we don't have
those laws
anymore but he's guilty he he is guilty
uh he also uh is a racist apparently
according to his own words listen to
this one I know I'm Prejudice I know I'm
bigoted in a lot of different ways you
know and I've said this before if I see
a black kid in a hoodie at night on the
other side of the street bouncing you
know I'm probably on the same side of
the street I'm probably going to walk to
the other side of the
street he's a bigot he's a bigot and he
knows he's a bigot he sees a black guy
in a hoodie he's gonna walk oh well
it turned out to be Michael Jordan that
was a mistake why' I do that um by the
way uh for somebody that loves diversity
equity and inclusion when it comes down
to something that's based in meritocracy
like sports uh he's not a real fan of
diversity equity and inclusion because
there are currently on the Dallas
Mavericks the team of which he is the
owner there there are 19 players two of
them are white uh I would think that if
you wanted a racially balanced team
you'd get a few more white people you
might throw an Indian in there uh you
might throw an Asian woman give me a
little something and and because I don't
just say these things right I I'm not
somebody that just gets up here and just
babbles for a living I put my money
where my mouth is uh I don't know if
you've seen this but I did try out for
the Dallas Mavericks last week and and
we're very excited to to show you this
next into the tank is a modern version
of a traditional
machine hey sharks I'm Dave ruin and I'm
here to try out for the Dallas
Mavericks what are your pronouns my
pronouns are she they how long have you
played for I've been playing for about
35 years but more importantly my
husband's gay what college did you play
at I played at Howard University a
historically black college oh cool who's
your favorite African-American Elon
Musk and what's your three point
percentage 30% is a she 42% as a they so
what's your vertical high enough to jump
Donald Trump's
wall okay and what would you say your
signature movie funding lower class
abortions from out of state hey what's
your favorite warm-up music The National
Anthem while kneeling all right I like
what I've seen so far you really love
the game but who who is your favorite
player growing up number 32 Carl Malone
sticking all kind of hell up they but
congratulations man you're the newest
member of the Dallas Mavericks all right
that's true I am now on the Dallas
Mavericks um they have cut was it Luca
Nik Luca Luca donic he's regular in
white they have got rid of him sure
triple double every night he's gone I'm
in uh Glenn Beck my buddy Glenn Beck uh
was on the Patrick Bet David podcast a
couple days ago and they were talking a
bit about Mark Cuban and then we will
move on from Mark Cuban after this so
yes Mark I'm poking and prodding you a
little bit but I I think we can get you
to the promis land here's Glenn four I
don't know him well enough I've done a
couple of interviews with him and I've
been around him a couple of times so I
have very little to go on but honestly
he might be very smart in a couple
things but when it comes to politics and
everything else the guy's a he
really is he just Cub he has no idea
what he is talking about he calls
himself a
libertarian I'll give you a Libertarian
metal detector there's nothing in his
body that would make that thing beep
there is nothing he's I don't know where
he thinks he's libertarian all right so
generally I think the point is that Mark
is just confused about these things but
there's a reason I've just spent the
last you know 12 or so minutes talking
about him because Mark represents to me
what I think most people are when it
comes to diversity equity and inclusion
and all this leftist nonsense they're
kind of confused they're a little guilty
like they're not they're not uh evil
like the intentions they have are not
evil but of course that road to hell is
often paved with good intentions so it's
sort of irrelevant if at the end you
bring people to the precipice of
destroying Western Society but now I
want to turn to some of the people that
I actually believe are doing it
intentionally and I do think it's
important that we make that distinction
between someone that's just a little
confused or whatever else and someone
that's absolutely doing it intentionally
one person who who has been ushering in
this nonsense intentionally and she is
PID
by a giant Corporation one of the
biggest corporations in the entire world
to put out her Neo rist nonsense every
day is Joy Reed of the televised mental
institution known as MSNBC Listen to
This Racist angry nonsense coming from
her I believe this is from yesterday uh
also note that if she had done this
about any other uh race of people she
probably would have been fired in
America there's a thing about both white
vigilantism and white tears
particularly male white
tears really white tear in general
because that's what carot are right they
caring out and then as soon as they get
caught bring
Waterworks white men can get away with
that too and it has the same effect even
as the right tries to politicize the
idea that masculinity is being robbed
from American men by multiculturalism
and wokeism they still want to be able
to have their
tears
it's really incredible what she's saying
there now first off masculinity is being
robbed and generally if you're going to
chop off a generation of young
children's genitals and confuse them
about a whole bunch of stuff yeah
masculinity will be robbed and then you
create a society of weak men and a
society of weak men create really bad
times and then it takes suddenly another
generation of strong men and it's hard
to grow strong men it's easy to grow
weak men uh eventually maybe they can
create good times again but we're we're
we seem to be in that transition stage
right now but what's interesting is is
she doesn't want it's not only that she
wants it to be that white people are
evil and all of those things but also
she doesn't want when she's like mocking
white tears what she doesn't want is
white the average white person who has
now been discriminated against at the to
get into the school in the first place
and then the job after that and then
maybe the the housing after that once
the EI gets into everything right like
and that's the thing it's leaked into
everything so if you are a 16-year-old
kid right now white or Asian or Jewish
kid right now the entire system is
rigged against you it is that is just a
fact now not here in Florida where we've
blown apart Dei thanks to Rhonda santis
but in most States it really isn't it's
not only not only in America it's it's
actually happening across Europe as well
the point is if you're a 16-year-old kid
who works real hard well now it's going
to be a little harder for you to get
into college and a little harder for you
to get into grad school and a little
harder to get that job and a little
harder to get into that apartment and a
little harder for you to get that
mortgage blah blah blah blah blah do you
think you might be racist by the time
you're 50 now it's 2042 the whole
system's been rigged against you you've
watched less qualified people qualified
people get by on the color of their skin
do you think you might be a little
racist so if you think we have a problem
with all of this now just wait to what
happens in 20 years uh but okay so
someone like Joy Reed she's obviously
not well-intentioned she she is a racist
she would gladly have
systemic uh racism built into the system
where we could discriminate against
white people and basically non- brown
and black people because that's that's
what she wants and that's what that's
what they have at the moment but she's
not the only one the other one of course
another one of these people is Anna
Navaro Anna Navaro who lives here in the
Free State of Florida and constantly
rails against all of our freedoms uh and
just spouts complete and utter nonsense
every day on The View uh this this one's
a true gem uh about how
America is just as racist as always en
Joy she you know very casually said
about uh all men are created equal that
did not include uh African-Americans did
not include women she said we fixed it
along the way as if it was a typo that
they said you know what let me fix that
let me cross that out and put no it took
a civil war
700,000 almost Americans died in that
Civil War you know what the equivalent
of 700,000 Americans are today almost 7
million Americans that would be the
equivalent today it took years and years
of women marching and fighting to get
equality it wasn't until a little over a
hundred years ago that the 18th
amendment was ratified you're making the
reverse point you
dingbat the people that fought for
equality the people who were writing the
documents as I always say Thomas
Jefferson George Washington the other
Founders many of them were writing the
docu ments that were ultimately going to
free the slaves we had a women's
suffrage movement that allowed
ultimately women to be able to vote and
everything else and black people got the
right to vote and all of the things that
led us to equality and then we got there
but you people said that's not good
enough so let's bring a whole bunch of
racism back and now it is it is your
functioning ethos that you push on us
every day and now you judge everyone's
decisions on whether they agree with you
when you look at someone only as to
whether they are black or brown or
sometimes whether they're just a chick
here is fake conservative Alysa Farah
Griffin uh basically saying that the
only reason Dan santis endorse Trump was
because Nikki Haley's a woman there's
some sexism we haven't talked about
Ronda santis actually intellectually
knows that Nikki Haley is more qualified
and more fit to be the GOP nominee he's
a Harvard grad he's a Yale undergrad he
served in the Navy he knows Donald Trump
is not better than her and he threw in
some jab at her she's like warmed over
corporatism I'm sorry it's giving sexism
I also think I like Chris Christie I
respect him him dropping out of the race
criticizing her in leaked audio and then
refusing to back her even though she's
the only person who could possibly beat
Donald Trump it feels like the boys
can't handle losing to women we are the
only n one of the only Western Nations
that's never elected a female president
Israel's had female prime ministers most
of your past there is some sort of a
sexism in our politics we've just never
been able to get over or maybe we just
haven't had the right woman yet right
Hillary Clinton got pretty damn close
and then the Democrat Party decided to
choose a black guy instead maybe Nikki
Haley will do something miraculous today
in New Hampshire and then the equation
will shift a little bit and then we
shall see but but the broader Point here
is that I like Ronda santz is not
backing Donald Trump over Nikki Haley
because she's a woman right like it's
just it's such thin nothingness right
it's just tepid water being poured on
people it's it's absolute nothing that
she is saying but what is Alyssa Farah
really good at she's really good at
cashing a check from a giant Corporation
ABC which is owned by Disney to be a pet
Republican to always support Republicans
who will never win so she likes Chris
Christie she was always trying to
undermine Ronda santis when he was a
threat now her main thing is she'll have
to take out Donald Trump and you have to
back the woman that's obviously not
going to win and then they get they give
her her cookie and she moves on but of
course it's not just the political layer
that that is the problem with all of
this because you know it's in the
educational layer in the cultural lay
and everything else uh but it's also
that every other piece of even if you
don't care about politics it starts
infecting your life one way or another
the Hollywood portion of this and as we
always talk about politics is Downstream
from culture and culture often generates
itself in Hollywood uh is is pretty
nasty these people have pushed drible on
us endlessly we've seen them destroy
Star Wars we've seen Disney completely
melt down uh and now there is a new
director I don't know if you know this
they're remaking the Wizard of Oz which
I cannot believe we had my my cousins my
niece and nephew over a couple weeks ago
we watched The Wizard of Oz it's it's
Perfection it's absolute perfection do
you guys even know this that The Wizard
of Oz is the first color movie of all
time so when the movie began when you
watch that opening of The Wizard of Oz
in black and white until they get to Oz
when it becomes color can you imagine
being in the movies what year to that
come out 193 1939 Brock you're not even
Googling that you just know that up the
top of your head Brock 1939 where's it R
can you imagine going to the movie
theater having only seen black and white
movies not that off of silent films and
then you go to the movie theater in 1939
and then you're 15 minutes into a movie
and then you see color like just try to
think how amazing that is anyway it's
it's Perfection it should never be
touched anyway of course they are
remaking uh The Wizard of Oz to be a
nonwhite Wizard of Oz they're also
remaking It's a Wonderful Life
by the same director her name is Kenya
Baris and uh you know she's just about
had it with you white people know you
can't say too much but what about your
perspective on it are you most excited
about people seeing in what I actually
want to ask about both of them both
Wizard of Oz and its Wonderful Life um
Wizard of Oz for me I you know it it
happens I'm from Englewood it happens
from a girl who lives in the bottoms
which is which is Darby Park which is a
part of Inglewood and it it takes place
under she falls into Inglewood and I it
the original Englewood took the original
Wizard of R took place during the Great
Depression you know was about
self-reliance and what people are going
through I think this is a perfect time
to sort of like switch with the
characters and talk about what someone
imagines their life could be it's
ultimately a hero's journey someone
think something is better than where
they're at and they go and and realize
that where they're at is where they
should be I want people to sort of be
proud and happy about where they're from
and but I want the world to take a look
at it um and I hope that would could
come through okay first off I guess I
have to make a correction there Kenya
appears to be a man I mean who am I to
decide what someone's gender is but we
had we did a quick run through on the
show this morning so I guess that's a
man but the point is nobody needs to
remake these things was The Wizard of Oz
like if you're if you think the Wizard
of Oz wasn't gay enough for you you are
so gay you should be studied by
scientists right like you don't think
that the that the Tin Man and the
Scarecrow and the and the uh the lion I
mean these were these people I don't
know what they were doing you know what
I mean anyway what Dei leads to is an
endless decline in everything our
products will not be as good because
they will not be designed by the best
Engineers our our bridges will not be as
good our movies will not be as good our
our TV shows I think I've mentioned to
you once or twice I have a friend who I
cannot uh say her his or her name but
it's a chick a real chck um but she is a
legendary actress in Hollywood a comedy
actress many many sitcoms over the years
and uh she basic I can't really say this
it'll it'll give it away too much anyway
they've destroyed everything in
Hollywood can I just leave it at that um
but it's not just of course the products
it's not just of course the culture and
the movies and everything else now to
get us back to the beginning of the show
remember Greg Gutfeld was talking about
how if one thing maybe could stand up
against Dei it should be our military
because it does not matter if our
soldiers are straight they must at least
be able to shoot straight uh but this is
video of trump appointed General Mark
Millie uh showing you how important he
believes wokeism is and things that he
wants to understand related to this new
age racism and I I want to understand
white rage and I'm white and I want to
understand it so what is it that caused
thousands of people to assault this
building and try to overturn the
Constitution of the United States of
America what caused that I want to find
that out I want to maintain an open mind
here and I do want to analyze it it's
important that we understand that
because our soldiers Sailors Airmen
Marines and Guardians they come from the
American people so it is important that
the leaders now and in the future do
understand it I've read miles SE Tong
I've read I've read KL Marx I've read
lenon that doesn't make me a communist
so what is wrong with understanding
having some situational understanding
about the country for which we are here
to defend actually you should read the
documents but it doesn't mean that
they're all good you could read Marxist
documents and then be like oh well now I
understand why this is complete driil
but instead you guys have decided to
read the ideas of diversity Equity
inclusion and then import them into the
army and if you don't think that this is
infecting the Army well actually the US
Army now has its smallest military force
in 80 years with the largest drop coming
from surprise surprise white recruits
and then you know what happens it's not
just the military that that happens with
what happens is in police forces in blue
cities and blue states that have brought
this woke woke nonsense in you get old
uh older more professional police
officers retiring like NYPD which
basically the NYPD was as big as a as a
small army in its Heyday and kept New
York City safe especially if you look at
that 20-year Rudy Giuliani Mike
Bloomberg run uh they have basically
forced a gajillion people into
retirement then because nobody wants to
be part of the new NYPD anymore because
their officers get abused they're not
allowed to use Force etc etc uh they
feel that they're going to end up in
jail if they actually ever do any
policing uh then they've lowered the
recruits uh they've lowered the
qualifications for the recruits so now
you have police officers who are fat and
who can't run or and unathletic and not
that bright and a whole bunch more and
this is happening all over blue cities
in America uh this one is absolutely
wild out of California uh because
Oakland Oakland which has turned into a
complete almost San Francisco level and
it's pretty close to San Francisco
almost San Francisco level dystopian
nightmare uh it imported all all of the
Dei stuff demolished its Police
Department there's crime and drugs
everywhere and now guess what's
happening in Oakland they are closing
and in and out I I cannot believe this
In-N-Out if you've never been to
In-N-Out Burger when we we've talked
about on the show before we go through
our favorite Burgers someone's going to
say Five Guys over here someone's going
to say uh you like The Shake Shack you
like that BurgerFi In-N-Out is the best
burger chain in the country they have
never closed a chain before but adios
they can't take it in Oakland anymore s
and alberger plans to close its only
Restaurant in Oakland because of crime
in that area the burger chain released a
statement saying the restaurant near the
Oakland Airport will be closing March
24th Saban says despite taking repeated
actions to make things safer for
customers and employees they're still
regularly the victims of car break-ins
property damage thefts and armed
robberies and the company statement also
said quote this location remains a busy
and profitable one for the company but
our top priority must be the safety and
well-being of our customers and
Associates we cannot ask them to visit
or work in an unsafe environment the
company also said that all employees
will be offered either a transfer to
another in an our location or offered
severance pay you guys get how crazy
that is it is not surprising that stores
can't survive because of crime in
Oakland but they're telling you we're
still profitable we're still busy and
profitable we can't keep this open cuz
it's not safe for our employees to work
here because they're breaking into the
cars they're stealing the food etc etc
and Oakland is going to do jack
about it because diversity equity and
inclusion destroys everything it
destroys Harvard and it destroys
everything down to your local border
joint and then now let's take this to
the meta level of what's going on in the
country it also destroys the Border uh
This is Wild there was a massive Supreme
Court ruling yesterday and and it is
just absolutely terrible we've got a
tweet here from Greg price breaking the
Supreme Court just ruled 5 to4 that the
Biden Administration can remove physical
barriers Texas Texas put up at their
border to stop The Invasion Barrett and
Roberts voted with the Liberals I mean
this is absolutely insane a bit more
from Bill maluan over at Fox who does a
great job going down to the Border
breaking the Supreme Court has ruled
that the Biden Administration could
resume removal of the razor wire
installed by the state of Texas along
the border near Eagle Pass at least
while litigation is ongoing Thomas Alo
Gorsuch and Kavanaugh all dissented
Roberts and Barrett sided with the left
leaning justices to rule in the Biden
administration's favor and allow border
patrol to remove the razor wire the
majority of the razor wire is deployed
in the Shelby Park area of Eagle Pass a
city owned a city-owned property that
the state of Texas recently seized
control with armed soldiers and kicked
the federal government out in order to
moove the wire Texas has to allow border
patrol back in if they refuse what
happens this is potentially setting up a
significant State vers Federal Showdown
if push comes to shove and let me show
you some video of this this is
absolutely
incredible so this is them removing now
look at this they have got a truck
forklift basically lifting up the barbed
wire so that people can just wander in
so the federal government has decided
not to do its job okay the federal
government is not doing one of its basic
simple it's a simple job actually
because you know where a border is you
know how to defend it and the Supreme
Court has said okay the federal
government isn't going to do it Texas
tried to do a little something we're
going to screw you over Texas and you're
not going to be able to do anything
either uh this is going to set up a
massive fight between the states and the
federal government and maybe we need to
have it because the Supreme Court is
basically saying to Texas well you can
either secede from the union or you can
just die a slow death you can just be
completely invaded or you can get the
hell out of America because we're not
going to protect you so I 100% stand
with uh with Greg Abbot the governor of
Texas I stand with the people of Texas
and you have no the federal government
is not only it's not that they're just
negligent they are intentionally awful
the fact that Comey Barrett who everyone
thought was going to you know really
make this a conservative leaning
law-abiding Supreme Court and John
Roberts that they voted alongside the
Liberals on this I mean this is this is
evil evil evil stuff but they continue
to lie about everything and uh you know
this right the Alexander suan it's in we
quote we know they're lying they know
they're lying they know that we know
they're lying and they continue to lie
uh here's some compilations of Biden
Cala Harris mayorcas and a whole bunch
of mothers just lying about the border
now we just showed you or in case you
forget we just showed you video of a
forklift uh lifting up barbed wire to
let people into the country does that
seem like a safe border here's the lying
Liars lying it is my testimony that the
border is secure the president have
worked very hard to implement a strategy
when it comes to the border that is
Humane safe and and has orderly
enforcement things are going at the
border sir much better than much better
than you all
expected we
have a secure Border in that that is a
priority for Any Nation including ours
in our Administration we have responded
with a model approach that has proven to
work we have taken unprecedented action
over the past year and a half to secure
our border and we have a process in
place to manage migrants of the Border
we're working to make sure it's safe and
orderly and Humane the border is closed
we agree that uh the border is secure
we're executing a comprehensive strategy
to secure our borders one of our highest
priorities is to ensure that we have a
secure border and that is what we are
doing we are stopping the flow at the
border the border is secure these people
should all be be impeached or removed
from their job like that's what the
Republicans should be pushing on more
than anything else you want to impeach
Joe Biden I mean I think it's a waste
anyway over the hunter Biden stuff you
impeach him over this mayorcas has got
to go these people are lying but I get
it the system does not work as it should
but we must keep exposing them for it
now one interesting thing is there seems
to be one San Democrat and I cannot
believe this this man deserves an award
I would like to send this man an award
the one sane Democrat is the senator
from Pennsylvania the guy that we all
thought had brain damage has turned out
to be the one sane Democrat it's wild
yes it's John fetman making
sense because obviously a lot of
progressives on Twitter have been
attacking you for your position on
Israel uh for noting that in your
opinion um saying that there is a crisis
at the border does not make one uh
xenophobic um why do you think you've
been so criticized by so many
progressives I I honestly don't
understand I I don't understand why it's
controversial to anybody to decide that
you're going to stand with Israel in
this situation I honestly don't
understand why it's controversial to say
we we need a secure border uh and I
think two things can be true at the same
time you can be very supportive
immigration but we also need to have a
secure border and I really I think about
immigration is we want to provide the
American dream for any migrant but it
seems very difficult when you have
300,000 people showing up encountered at
at our quarter to do that and I think we
need to to re do a reset and we have to
work together uh and develop uh a new
comprehensive solution to that John
fedan is like the movie Awakenings do
you guys see the movie Awakenings
remember it's Robert dairo and and Robin
Williams is the doctor and they start
dairo is in like a coma and they put him
on this experimental medication and he
sort and he comes back to life and he's
he's okay again fman when he sort of had
brain damage was a progressive now he's
getting out of that like whatever
happened to him medically he's getting
out of that and he's becoming a
conservative it's a freaking Miracle but
okay fedman calling out his own side now
it's interesting he keeps saying I don't
really understand it now I think we've
laid out a case over the last 45 minutes
or so that there is a way to understand
what these people are doing that they
are marxists they don't like our
freedoms they don't like individual
choice they don't like America they
don't like our founding all those things
I think Federman ironically will get
there it seems like he is on his way and
and we'll see how he becomes an aema to
the to the rest of the party as the goes
off the deep end but I want to connect
this to something else that we showed
you last week and we've showed you
before but it is worth noting again uh
this is from about six months ago when
Bernie Sanders went on billah and billah
asked him about the difference between
equality and Equity because these people
simply when when John fedman says well I
don't really get it yet you can he's
look he's trying to find the answers
that isn't stark contrast to Someone
Like Bernie Sanders who has been a
lifelong socialist who became a
millionaire with three houses in our
capitalist system who has ushered in all
this nonsense and when when given the
slightest push back on his ideas can you
just explain socialism 101 the
difference between equity and equality
he simply doesn't know anything so the
reason I'm showing you this clip again
is you must understand that a lot of the
people that were fighting against yeah
they were bad guys like Joy Reed but
then there are sort of confused people
like Mark Cuban and there are bad guys
like Joy Reed and then there's a whole
bunch of people like Bernie Sanders who
don't even know what they're saying and
that's why if you're still a Democrat
right now or you're left leading call
out your own side before they go off
into the abyss Dei are we confusing
equality of opportunity with trying to
guarantee equity and outcomes okay
that's interesting because I think this
word Equity has come into the language
in the last few years and before that we
didn't hear it a lot and I think a lot
of people hear equity and they hear
equality that it's the same word and
it's not the same word in the same
concept cep so how would you
differentiate between equity and
equality well equality we talk about uh
I don't know what the answer to that is
come me to think of it you know uh
equality is equality of opportunity all
right we live in a society we want all
people right to have whatever color your
skin is equity I think is more guarantee
of outcome is it
not yeah I think so I think that's okay
so which do you come which side do you
come on uh equality equality yeah okay
I'm sorry that clip will never get old I
don't know how many more times we're
going to show you that but like it will
never get old that should have ended the
grift right there Bernie should have
just moved left gone into a cave
somewhere moved into one of his three
houses and never been seen again but the
point is a bunch of people who don't
really know what they're talking about
Mark cubin and a bunch of people who
have pushed this nonsense and have no
idea what they're talking about Bernie
Sanders they've they've somehow taken
over the whole narrative but now a whole
whole bunch of us are pushing back even
John freaking fedman so what do you do
call out your own side congratulations
to Bill Maher who's been doing it for a
long time even if even if he doesn't get
to the conclusion I want him to get to
congratulations to John fedman who's
doing it right now but even more
importantly than that regardless of what
political side you're on provide provide
a better Vision a positive Vision an
inspirational Vision something that
actually shows and illustrates and
illuminates your alternative to the Dei
framework it's something like
meritocracy something like the things
that America was founded upon chapiro
and Elon Musk so when you look at the
state of the West right now you somebody
maybe it's all the Doom scrolling but
when you when you uh you know look at
the state of the West right now you're
very optimistic it sounds like uh you
know I I find it hard to be optimistic
in uh In This Moment it's been a very
ugly couple of years you know from
Ukraine to the current conflict in
Israel and Hamas uh to domestic politics
in the United States everywhere else it
seems like there's a lot of polarization
a lot of
fragmentation what do you think is the
future of of the West can we come
together around any sense of shared
common values you
know I think I think there are some
things that we can agree on or most
people would agree on are cool and
inspiring like um Humanity going to the
Moon you know if you ask probably kids
almost anywhere in the world what's the
coolest thing humans have ever
done I think a lot of kids would say we
went to the
moon you know um and uh I so I think we
want to continue that spad of
exploration um you know speaking of kind
of growing the pie and is is that we we
want to I think have a dream that we can
be uh space bearing civilization a
multiplet species a multi- stellar
species and go out there among the stars
and and discover the nature of the
universe um that we can collectively
seek greater
Enlightenment um to better understand
this Incredible Universe we live
in
um I find that very compelling I I think
I think most people would find that very
compelling I think embedded in that it's
also as you say that core value of
meritocracy because it's one thing to
say man can go to the moon it's another
thing to say I can be part of man going
to the moon and a meritocracy suggests
that you can be part of that it's not
just that human beings are capable of
doing the thing it's that you can be a
part of that thing if you work hard
enough if you innovate enough if you try
hard enough and so societies that seem
to have given up on that also seem to
have given up on on going to the Moon
societies that are so reflective about
their own supposed flaw
the United States has this problem right
now that they that they are unwilling to
to Simply say freedom is pretty
phenomenal and and meritocracy is the
greatest thing that's ever been invented
and we should hold on to that and that's
what's going to allow us to get to the
mo that that stops us from going to the
moon or to Mars or to anywhere else so
the choice is yours guys you can Naval
gaze and try to think back to all of our
problems and were we racist once and was
someone mean to me and I've got problems
in the world's against me and I'm this
color and I'm this gender and I'm this
sexuality and woe is me I'm going to
burn everything down and nobody will go
over a bridge again and I'm G to burn
that baby or you could say you know what
I've got some skills I've got some worth
I've got some value I'm going to try to
do something on this planet and not only
I'm going to do something on this planet
but maybe we'll start going to other
planets and maybe we can actually go to
the Undiscovered Country and we can
uncover the mysteries of the universe
and maybe within our lifetimes we can be
on other planets and doing things that
are that are
absolutely magical things that we cannot
even think of at the moment might just
Beyond the Horizon with AI and planetary
travel and so much more so which one of
those sounds inspirational to you which
one of those sounds aspirational to
you you tell me part one of my interview
with Mike Baker former CIA operative
Mike Baker super interesting interview
it is up across platforms now the full
thing up on locals at the moment uh
people of the internet is live at 1 pm
today that's in about 55 minutes from
now a postgame show coming up right this
very moment Ruben report. locals.com we
leave you with the world economic Forum
reminder those are not the good guys and
we'll see you
tomorrow I my
why sh
[Applause]
ie
[Music]
w